yesterday I had the opportunity to
testify at a house Committee hearing to
voice my support for legislation Banning
the castration mutilation of children in
Tennessee now I've addressed School
boards in the past as you know but this
was my first time in front of any kind
of legislative committee so it was an
interesting learning experience kind of
like my own Schoolhouse Rock sort of uh
experience and one of the key difference
differences here is that in my school
board speeches I've spoken out against
policies and measures that the boards
were wanting to put into place or or had
already put into place in this case
however I was speaking in favor of a
bill that the majority of the
legislature has already expressed
support for so I didn't need to convince
them of what they already believe or
urge them to do what they're already
going to do but rather my plan was
simply to add my voice of support as a
citizen of the state now
you may be understandably concerned
based on that description that my
appearance in front of this committee
must have been rather boring and lacking
the kind of fireworks that you might
expect and hope for well allow me to
allay those fears because fortunately
for you there were a few Democrats in
the room who though on the losing side
of this issue were still determined to
use my appearance as an opportunity to
try and score some points with their own
base so after I delivered my brief
remarks and all the other witnesses
there were three others on the
anti-mutilation side and four on the
pro-mutilation side they had they had
their turns also to uh to speak and then
the lawmakers on the committee had the
chance to ask us questions and the first
question came from a republican who had
a very fair and relevant query about the
off-prepeated claim which we also heard
from other Witnesses during the
testimonies that medically affirming
quote unquote translated identified
youth is necessary to decrease their
suicide rate and because this is the
thing that got everything kicked off I
want to play this clip for it's a little
bit long but um it's also it's uh it's
an important Point too so here's my
answer to his question
just a quick question for you we've
heard in the news last week
and even today that
it's pro-life to vote against this bill
we've heard that um
suicides are prevalent
and suicide has impacted my family so
I'm sensitive when I hear something like
that
I I I've read some of the stuff that
you've done and I was wondering can you
speak to the statistics
of of
Mental Health
and Suicidal Tendencies
for the people who have gone through
transition and for people who have not
in your studies from what I've read can
you can you speak to that you recognized
sure well the claim that uh you know
doing the chemical castration drugs or
surgery or hormonal intervention the
claim that this prevents suicide or has
a positive psychological effects down
the line is utterly totally baseless
there are no credible long-term studies
that bear that out and one of the
reasons for that is that there couldn't
possibly be any credible long-term
studies because we've never done this to
kids on this scale ever before in
history so this current uh shall we say
crop of children they are the guinea
pigs this is this is all experimental
we're sort of trying it out on them to
see if it works now they have attempted
a few times to do studies and the
interesting thing is that the world
Professional Association of transgender
Health wpath which is a radical far-left
pro-trans organization they commissioned
a study to try to prove that um that
hormones and puberty blockers a
decreased suicide rates among
trans-identified Youth and even in their
own study they found that they couldn't
they couldn't they couldn't prove it
they couldn't make that link because
it's just not possible to do the other
thing I've mention too is that
you know the the
number of trans identified youth has
skyrocketed in recent years we're
talking about exponential 10x 20x growth
just huge numbers having of a have
increased and what we hear from the
pro-trans side is that well this is not
a social contagion it's just that you
know there's always been this many trans
people it's just that they were not in
an affirming
uh environment before in history and so
they couldn't come out and now for the
first time trans people have have the
ability to live their truth so to speak
well if that's the case and there have
always been these sort of like millions
of trans people and if it's also true
that if we don't affirm them that it
would cause them to commit suicide then
we should be able to look back in
history and find just this unbroken
incredible epidemic of children
mysteriously killing themselves because
they weren't being affirmed as trans and
what you find is that that didn't exist
I mean the the youth suicide rate has
increased exponentially alongside trans
affirmation so trans affirmation causes
the suicide rate not the other way
around the last thing I'll note is that
um
the suicide rate among trans identified
people is is Sky High it remains Sky
High all the data shows us it remains
Sky High even after surgery and in fact
in the most reliable day that we have
it's a years after surgery when
suicidality is the highest for
trans-identified people that's the
reality
so you see all that I make a number of
claims and arguments in that answer
just as I did in my initial remarks that
the Democrats on the panel had the
opportunity to refute if indeed I was
wrong about anything I said and can be
refuted then they had the chance to do
it but but but they couldn't refute it
they had nothing to say which as we've
learned about Democrats will certainly
not stop them from talking so the next
question or what pretended to be a
question came from a greasy little hack
named Caleb hemmer who rather than
discussed the issue at hand instead
decided to try and smear me with that
Media Matters hit piece from my time as
a shock jock morning host 15 years ago
what does that have to do with anything
what what did he think he would
accomplish with this well we'll find out
thank you Mr Walsh I found it
interesting one of our uh uh people
testified today that they uh had their
gender affirming surgery at 16 and I
know uh you and former comments
mentioned uh this uh on your blog at
about 16 you're an adult who's mature
and can make decisions uh you're that at
16. I don't care what anybody says even
going so far as to say you know 16
people when you're 16 you should be
married and uh and could be pregnant or
should be pregnant so I'm curious if 16
is uh a uh an adult in your view why is
this bill have the minor defined as 18.
yeah that's that's a hit piece you took
from Media Matters uh from something
when I was a radio host uh 13 14 years
ago in my early 20s it's also not an
accurate reflection of what I actually
said I was talking about
uh the fact that people tended to marry
young historically and that's all that
that was about
um
how does that relate to this
subject
just curious your definition of if you
feel like people are adults at 16 should
well people are adults at 18. but
actually they're your your brain is not
fully developed until you're 25.
so we should be having a conversation
about whether we should even be doing
these surgeries to people at 18. but
certainly before 18 it's it's absurd
I mean do you do you think that a 16
year old can meaningfully consent to
having their body parts removed
do you
no
we do not yeah we ask the questions it's
not it's
uh representative Hammer you are
recognized
so that was one gloriously awkward
silence uh even more so for those of us
in the room actually you can't see it
from that camera angle on the clip
exactly but Caleb sat back away from the
microphone when I asked him that
question and he kind of looked off to
the side almost like he was trying to
pretend he didn't hear the question was
it was a it was a bizarre scene but not
so bizarre when you consider that I had
asked a question that Caleb hemmer
simply could not answer he obviously
couldn't say no that 16 year olds can't
consent to having body parts improved
because then he'd be agreeing with me
and with the legislation he doesn't want
to do that but he also didn't want to
come out and say yes that 16 year olds
can consent because that sounds horrific
and insane when said out loud and it
puts him in the position of having to
explicitly defend a totally indefensible
proposition you'll notice it left us
they often find themselves in this kind
of situation they they hold many views
that they cannot say out loud
their actual positions on the issues are
often so deranged so inconceivably gross
so morally vacuous and incoherent that
you can defeat them in an argument
simply by asking them to clearly State
their own premise
of course what this means is that
leftists like uh you know leftists
themselves left us like Caleb hemmer
they themselves realize how evil their
own policies are they are deliberately
pushing things that they recognize as
unspeakably wicked which is why they
will not speak it out loud
and this puts people like Caleb Hammer
somewhere somewhere below mere partisan
hacks you've got partisan hacks and then
it's below them that you have the Caleb
hammers of the world
because these are people who are
consciously evil
which also explains why they would
resort to smear tactics against a
private citizen at a legislative hearing
keep in mind by the way that I was not
there as an author of the bill nor was I
testifying as some sort of accredited
expert I didn't stand up there and say
I'm a medical expert and a doctor and
this is what
in fact I introduced myself as uh I'm a
citizen Tennessee I'm a husband and a
father and this is how I feel about this
um a citizen of Tennessee who supports
the bill and this is supposed to be a
democracy they tell me right
so the point is that even if they could
succeed in tearing me down and
embarrassing me which sadly for them
they didn't how would that remotely come
close to proving that the legislation is
bad
now if you're wondering how Caleb hemmer
will recover from this humiliation well
he'll do it or he'll try to do it the
most weasily and dishonest way possible
of course so shortly after the hearing
Ben Shapiro posted that full exchange
that you just watched and he posted he
posted it to Twitter
uh hammer responded to the post with a
link to a different video which he urged
people to watch instead to see what
quote really went down now that video
was an edited montage by an obscure
left-wing propaganda rag called the
Tennessee holler and what they did is
they took all the questions that the uh
and not really questions but statements
that the Democrats on the Committee
hearing made to me and they spliced all
that together and then cut out most of
my responses
and then anything else that may have
been especially embarrassing for the
Democrats and pasted all the rest of it
together with a bunch of very obvious
jump cuts and posted that so hammer
therefore is actually claiming that an
edited Montage without my responses is a
more accurate reflection of what
actually transpired than the full
unedited clip that's how Shameless this
guy is
by the way if you're concerned about his
lack of honesty um and this lack of
honesty from an elected official
or perhaps you're not satisfied with his
refusal to answer my simple question
you could always reach out to him on any
of his social media channels and look
I'm not telling you I want to be very
clear about this I am not telling you
that I want you all to spam his Twitter
and his Facebook and Instagram that I
want hundreds of the you know comments
and everything attacking him I I'm not
I could not tell you to do that I
couldn't tell you to do that
I just want to make sure that you have
his information so that you can reach
out to him to express your concerns
again he's a he's elected official so
you can find him on Twitter at
calebhemmer that's
c-a-l-e-b-h-e-m-m-e-r or Instagram the
same way that you go to Facebook you
have facebook.com Caleb hemmer TN and
then calebhemper.com contact will take
you to his website and that's the
contact information for his office so
again if you have any concerns about the
behavior of this public official or if
you really want to know like does he
think that 16 year olds can consent to
having body parts removed he still
hasn't answered that question but I I
bet he'd love an opportunity to answer
it and I and I think he's he he would he
would want to hear from you be very glad
to hear from you so you can always do
that if you want
now there's more though the next
question came from Democrat John Ray
Clemens who also had no interest in
talking about the substance of the issue
instead with the slander already covered
by Caleb hemmer Clemens went to the
Democrats second favorite tool in the
box which is credentialism let's watch
can you give us a summary of your
educational background or your health
care education experience Mr Walsh you
recognized my experience in healthcare
your educational background I'm just
curious you you testified as to a lot of
your own research so I'm curious for
what purpose you do that and what
background you have to qualifies you to
speak to that well my background that
qualifies me to speak to this is that
I'm a human being with a brain and
common sense and I have a soul
and so therefore I think it's a really
bad idea it's a chemically castrate
children that is my experience
um also I I did now it's true I didn't I
didn't go to college but I did go to
school long enough to learn how to read
so I could read the data for myself and
that's exactly what I've done
representative Clements here and for
what purpose do you um
conduct your research and use this brain
of yours Mr Walsh you're recognized
I use it for the purpose of trying to
protect children from being castrated
and mutilated that's one of the things I
try to do
yeah thank you Mr chairman you don't use
it to get clicks on your stabilitation
well are you using it right now to try
to get clicks with this interaction
on no I I I I I I really like the idea
of getting uh of drawing attention to
the fact that this is happening to
children I know you seem to find it very
amusing I don't
yes what qualifies me to speak up
against chopping body parts off of kids
which credentials give me the right to
form an opinion about the sterilization
of middle schoolers I wonder what John
Ray Clements might have said if I told
him that um I'm also against drowning
bags of puppies in the river I'm not
even a big dog guy but like I don't
think that you should put puppies in a
bag and drown them in the river if I
were to tell them that would even
demanded to know what veterinarian
school I attended
this apparently comes as a shock to Mr
Clements but using your brain and your
conscience it's not the kind of job that
requires a resume or professional
references that's something you're
supposed to be doing all the time
especially when it comes to this
particular issue
but this is all they have they cannot
challenge me on the merits they cannot
debate me on the substance of the issue
they cannot explain why I'm wrong so
instead they will make the case that
whether I'm wrong or right I shouldn't
be saying anything at all
that is real that's the entire argument
that is the only argument I have heard
from these people uh since since I
started talking about this this issue
years ago the only argument they have it
really only boils down to you shouldn't
be talking about this
yet they can't even make that case
convincingly so instead they're left
with the bumbling ridiculous mess you
just witnessed
now there were more questions or
questions I should say after the
exchange we you just saw there another
Democrat representative started reading
my tweets where I advocate for capital
punishment for drug traffickers now what
in the world could that possibly have to
do with the bill in question
well he couldn't explain that
and I didn't have a chance to point out
how irrelevant it was because they
wouldn't let me respond either
so after that happened they basically
got tired of me answering and so for
most of the rest of the time it was just
them talking to me and then if I try to
speak they bang the gavel no this is not
this is not it's not time for responding
democracy in action folks isn't it
inspiring
but this is all predictable of course I
don't want you to think that I was
surprised or caught off guard that was
their intention but unfortunately they
were using the same tactics on me that a
million hacks and charlatans before them
have already used
what I'll say to the Democrats on the
committee is this if you want to Rattle
me with smears and irrelevant out of
context quotes and bad faith questions
and accusations Etc you're gonna have to
try a lot harder than that
a lot harder
or instead
instead of trying to get better at being
gutless smear merchants and disgraceful
hacks you could instead work on becoming
better people
better men
you could stop trying to defend the
indefensible
what you you what you yourself know to
be indefensible you could stop trading
in your soul for the sake of promoting
and defending the most depraved
ideological agenda mankind has ever
known
and instead you could try to be men of
dignity and integrity and moral courage
that's the other option
it's an option that would work out a lot
better for you in a lot of ways
including come Judgment Day I would add
and in the meantime
another bonus maybe it won't make such
asses of yourself in any more committee
hearings
just a thought
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Friday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign